in july of 2010 boeing aimed to have
starliner ready for crude missions by
2015.
yet here we are in 2021 and there's
still no clear end in sight for the
starliner capsule
throughout the program's lifetime nasa
has ported a total of 4.2 billion
dollars
but the starliner has simply seen delay
after delay
and failure after failure meanwhile
spacex has already started to complete
crude missions with crew dragon
so what happened to boeing starliner
well starting off let's take a look back
at the origins and evolution of the
starliner
it all started in 2010 when nasa
announced a commercial crew program
they were just about to retire the space
shuttle so they wanted an alternative to
get cruise to iss from america
boeing would initially receive 18
million dollars in 2010.
this funding was to be used to draft
designs and concepts and basically get a
crew spacecraft
on the board following this initial
funding nasa would pour in another 93
million dollars into nasa in 2011.
this money was to be used to refine
their prototypes and pitch the best
solution to nasa
at the same time nasa was also funding
other organizations such as spacex
blue origin and the sierra nevada
corporation
nasa tasked all of these companies with
developing their own crude spacecraft
modules
or parts of a potential spacecraft for
instance blue origin received 22 million
to develop a bionic nose cone spacex
received 75 million to develop crew
dragon
and the sierra nevada corporation
received 80 million dollars to develop
the dream chaser
it was said that the best designs would
qualify for the next stage of the
commercial crew program
and receive more funding but as you
might have noticed from the very
beginning
boeing received more funding than all of
the competition boeing was the only
company to receive a total
of over 100 million dollars and this gap
would only get bigger with time
while that may sound unfair it does make
sense
boeing was by far the most established
aircraft manufacturer
out of their group so it made sense for
nasa to hedge their bets with the boeing
soon enough boeing would land on the
starliner and this would win them 460
million dollars in 2012
but they weren't the only winners all
the main companies won money
sierra nevada would win 212.5 million
dollars
and spacex would win 440 million dollars
blue origin was also qualified to win
money
but they decided to turn down the
winnings and instead opt for funding
from jeff bezos
anyways over the next two years the
remaining companies would conduct a
plethora of tests and certifications
that nasa required
nasa would then judge the data gathered
from these tests as well as the
capability of each spacecraft
to choose the final two winners as we
all know the winners would end up being
boeing and
spacex boeing would end up winning 4.2
billion dollars
and spacex would end up winning 2.6
billion dollars boeing was clearly
favored at this point and things would
progress smoothly up until 2016.
in may of 2016 boeing announced that
they were facing issues with their
launch vehicle the atlas 5
and that the first crude flight would be
delayed till early 2018.
in october of 2016 boeing would further
push back this date to late 2018
and later that same year in december of
2016 spacex would also delay the crew
dragon to 2018
after the ammo 6 explosion so at this
point
both companies were more or less still
uneven grounds but
this created a rather significant issue
for nasa
you see the first flights of the
commercial crew program were scheduled
to take place by 2017
this was intended to give nasa plenty of
time to transition from relying on
russia
to rely on spacex and boeing considering
this delay
nasa would go ahead and purchase a
couple more seats on soyuz
which would be scattered throughout 2017
2018 and 2019
meanwhile we wouldn't hear very much
from boeing about starliner for the next
two years
but eventually more issues would surface
in july of 2018
boeing would experience an issue with
the report engine during testing
boeing didn't describe the issue in too
much detail saying that there was simply
an anomaly
speculation suggested that there may
have been a fuel leak
and it was later confirmed that this was
the case due to faulty valves
this would of course lead to another
delay in the program the first uncrewed
mission was pushed back to april of 2019
and the first crude mission was pushed
back to august of 2019
by the time april of 2019 rolled around
though boeing would announce that the
uncrewed flight was delayed
august of 2019 with the crude flight
likely falling in 2020
at this point it seemed like we were
just saying delay after delay
and that nothing was moving forward but
fortunately things would start to change
in may of 2019.
in may starliner would successfully
complete a major test that would open up
the path to their first orbital test
flight
the only test left before the orbital
flight was the abort test
boeing would go ahead and conduct the
abort test in november of 2019
unfortunately one out of the three
parachutes were not deployed during the
test
however two parachutes would be more
than enough to safely land the starliner
and so the test would be deemed a
success despite the minor failure
boeing would move on to their first
orbital test flight just one month later
in december of 2019
this wouldn't go very smoothly though
throughout the entire test we would see
a variety of software errors and
mishaps first of all a timing error
would lead to starliner's thrusters
consuming more fuel than expected
after this starliner would actually fail
in docking with the international space
station
and to make things even worse there
would be another thruster error during
re-entry
nasa would later reveal that the docking
error as well as a re-entry error
likely would have resulted in a loss of
the spacecraft if it wasn't for
intervention from ground control
so clearly this was a pretty serious
issue and we still have no clue how
these errors got past all the tests on
the ground
on the bright side though boeing would
take responsibility for the failure
and they would take on the full
financial responsibility of conducting a
second unquote orbital test flight
which comes out to about 410 million
dollars throughout 2020 boeing would
work on troubleshooting the errors they
encountered in the first test flight
and as of the time of this recording
they are ready to progress with the
second test flight
originally the launch was scheduled for
march 25th 2021
but this was later delayed april 2nd
however considering that nasa is working
on completing a crew mission with spacex
in april
it doesn't seem like boeing will end up
being able to test starliner in april
at this point though we're really just
looking at logistical and technical
delays
if the second orbital test flight is
successfully completed within the next
couple of months
then the first crude starliner mission
is planned for december of 2021.
i am not quite sure if this timeline
will play out but
if the second orbital test flight is
successful i think it's highly likely
that we'll see a crude dollar on a
mission by the end of 2022
assuming everything goes smoothly boeing
will have the opportunity to complete at
least five more crews dollar emissions
with nasa
over the next couple of years and if
those go smoothly
nasa will re-examine the cost and
reliability of starliner and go from
there
so though this program has dragged on
for way longer than expected
it does seem like we're finally going to
see starliner fulfill its goal
that's honestly an awesome milestone as
having multiple commercial crude launch
vehicles is only a good thing
but this still leaves one question on
the table why did it take boeing so long
and how is spacex able to beat boeing to
a crude launch with 1.6 billion
less in funding well in my opinion the
first major obstacle for boeing was a
lack of focus
this isn't to say that the engineers
working on starliner were unfocused
rather starliner wasn't a priority to
the executives and leaders at boeing
here's the thing boeing is an aircraft
manufacturer and thus far they have been
a very successful one
at that as a result starliner is just an
expansion to their business
not their main business itself so it
makes sense their primary focus was
always their aircrafts themselves
with spacex on the other hand crew
dragon was by far their most significant
project
of course their long-term goal was
always starship and mars
but successfully completing coup dragon
was critical in building up credibility
and investor trust aside from starliner
not being a top priority for boeing
boeing was also facing significant
issues with their core business
which likely consumed a lot of their
attention first of all we had the
massive fiasco with the boeing 737 max
8.
on march 13th 2019 the boeing 737 max 8
was grounded after claiming the lives of
346 people
at the time boeing had thousands of
boeing 737 maxi orders lined up and
ready to go
and as you would guess this fiasco led
to a massive downfall of boeing's
fundamental business which would of
course take priority
since then most countries have approved
the 737 max 8 for flight
but to this day china has yet to lift
the ban so clearly
boeing still very much feels the effects
of the 737 max 8
even today and it's very possible that
this issue hindered boeing from being
able to complete their first orbital
flight successfully
boeing has also faced another massive
issue which is of course the pandemic
airlines have been one of the hardest
hit industries due to pandemic
restrictions
and consequently it's not surprising
that demand for aircrafts has
significantly declined
boeing's profits started taking a hit
when the 737 max 8 was grounded
and things have only gotten worse since
between that time period their net
margin crashed from positive 10
to negative 20 that translates to a drop
in net income from a positive 10 billion
dollars per year
to a negative 11 billion dollars per
year i think nothing else has to be said
about boeing's financial situation
on top of facing a major downfall in
their primary business
i suspect that boeing underestimated how
fast spacex would develop crude dragon
while also overestimating their own
ability nasa favored boeing from the
very beginning
and this was with good reason i'm sure
that boeing really focused on starliner
and didn't face major issues with their
airline business
they could have likely started
conducting crude stolen emissions years
ago
i think the abundant confidence nasa had
in boeing likely got to their head
and prevented them from really
performing to the best of their ability
as we all know that is definitely not a
lack of ability that caused a rough path
for starliner why do you guys think
starlander had such major issues
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited to see starliner
finally complete a crude mission
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]